Hey it's me Destin, welcome to Smarter Every Day.
Have you ever just sat down and taken a really close look at nuts? I've been doing that for the
last few minutes, and I've come up with some pretty interesting observations. I mean cashews
and peanuts have very similar taste and texture, but they're fundamentally
different. Chances are if you live in the western world, you know exactly what a peanut plant
looks like, but you probably have no clue what a cashew plant looks like. Why is that?
Aah so this is what a cashew looks like.
(African) Yeah it is a what a cashew looks like.
(Destin) So is this.. do you eat this part?
Is this the nut?
-No this one. [...] you need get
dry. You gon take this and take it inside your fire, so you
after, there is a food inside, of this. Yeah.
(Destin) What about this? Can you eat this?
-Yeah this one you want to eat it
(Destin) It's a fruit? -yeah
(Destin) So that's cashew fruit. -yeah
And this is the cashew nut? -Cashew nut yeah
Aah. -If you want you can plant this. If you plant it, you have a cashew.
So cashew nut, cashew fruit. What does this taste like? Can I bite it? - yeah you can bite it
Is it good?
It's very good.. hmm.
Sweet. Very sweet.
I've never seen that before. See I didn't know that there was a
fruit. And these are cashew trees. Yeah I see.
If you don't know what a cashew plant looks like, it's because
you've never seen one because they don't grow in the climate where you're at.
Like most awesome foods, cashews were introduced to the Europeans
after the Spanish conquistadors came over, and they discovered it in South America
and Central America. They discovered cashews, peanuts, chocolate, vanilla, strawberries,
pineapples. Basically everything you need for a good banana split, except
the cow. I.. I thought it was interesting. Hope you're getting Smarter Every Day. I'm Destin. Bye.
Are you as fast as a rabbit? -nup
He's as fast as a rabbit? -he's not [...]
-he was lying down on [...]
When it's hot they can't move. -Yeah they can move, but you know sometimes..
They're like squirrels. Do you know
what a squirrel is. They're like squirrels in America.
We hunt squirrel where I come from. Yep. We eat them.
-it's nice?
uh No. It's not nice. It tastes bad.
[ Captions by Andrew Jackson ]